- You guys, I can't believe
it, but E3 is here, E3 2019.
The first place that we are stopping
here on the E3 week is the Xbox briefing.
So this is the Xbox press conference,
I don't know what they're gonna announce.
I have my fingers crossed for a new Xbox.
I've got my Yerba Mate,
I've got my sister Jenna.
- That's me.
- That's her.
- Hello, how are you?
Are you excited?
- I am so excited, are you ready to go in?
- I am.
- Okay, so,
let's go in.
- Yeah, it's hot.
- It is so hot out here.
- It's sneaky hot today.
- Steaming, woo, steaming.
Hey look, it's Ed!
- Same thing last year!
- Do you think you'll cry this year?
- I hope so,
- Yeah.
- It's a good thing if I cry.
- I cried last year.
Let's cut back to Ed crying.
(somber music)
- Don't.
- [Jenna] He did cry!
- [Justine] Yeah he did.
(upbeat rock music)
- [Female Announcer] Three.
Two.
One.
(audience cheers)
- [Male Announcer] This is
the Xbox E3 2019 Briefing.
(audience cheers)
- [Justine] Yeah, Phil!
- We on Team Xbox, live
for this exact moment.
The moment we get to share
the best of our art form
here with you in LA.
And the moment you get to experience
breathtaking new stories, new worlds,
and new heroes for the very first time.
(dramatic music)
- [Justine] What.
What?
Dude I have chills, that was super creepy.
Something else is happening!
What!
No!
Woah!
Holy S word.
- Hello Los Angeles.
(audience cheers)
- [Justine] Oh!
- Good to see you, thank you.
- I'm gonna cry, I think I'm gonna cry.
- Cyberpunk.
(audience laughs)
It's set in the metropolis of the future,
where body modification
has become an obsession.
You play as an outlaw,
an enhanced mercenary working
in the sleazy underbelly of the city.
- [Audience Member] Yeah Keanu!
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- You guys wanna know,
when is the release date?
(audience cheers and Justine laughs)
- [Justine] This is so good.
- All right, then check this out.
(audience cheers)
- [Justine] Soon!
Sort of.
Oh, holy what?
Oh yeah, all nine games.
All nine movies in one game.
(growling)
- [Male Voice In Game] The
attack, we lost everything.
- [Justine] Well there you go.
You were right.
Tyler's like, "I think it's Terminator".
It's Terminator.
(upbeat music)
- [Justine] Oh look at that!
(Justine cheers)
All right, I'm preordering right now.
- What?
Oh my god.
("Everything Is Awesome" by
Tegan and Sara feat. The Lonely Island)
I love Lego so much.
Is this for real?
Oh my god is this a Lego McLaren?
A Lego Ferrari?
What the heck is happening right now.
No way!
There it is!
Oh my god that's all made of Lego.
- So let's talk about our next console.
(audience cheers)
- This is what we're here for.
- This isn't just a console launch,
this is about the future of gaming.
- Your games, your achievements,
your progression, your accessories.
Your console gaming experience with Xbox,
it all comes forward with Scarlett.
(audience cheers)
- This is project Scarlett.
The most powerful and
highest performing console
we've ever designed.
We launched Xbox 18 years ago,
with the game reviewers called
the definitive reason to own an Xbox.
Because humanity was, and is worth saving.
Next holiday, we will launch
Project Scarlett with Halo.
- This is what we've been waiting for.
So it's over.
Project Scarlett looks incredible.
Halo Infinite launching 2020 holiday.
Okay well I just placed a
mobile order for Starbucks.
So we're gonna go get
Starbucks, kill some time
and then we're gonna be
going into the Xbox Showcase
and I'm hoping, fingers crossed,
that they have Lego Forza.
I couldn't believe it, I freaked out.
So our order is here.
We ordered so much stuff.
Okay, we've got, this one's mine.
This one (she laughs),
this one and then we have two more.
Wait no, this one's yours.
Tyler, are you kidding me?
Make sure there's no sweetener in it.
So we actually ordered two,
Jenna, how many did you order?
- Three.
- I ordered two.
Okay so now we have five.
- We have more coffee.
- This is super basic.
I'm embarrassed.
Look who we ran into at
Starbucks, it's Aaron.
We just finished the Xbox press
conference, it was so good.
- Aw thank you.
- What was your highlight?
There's a lot.
- I would say the most Xbox
shooter games we've ever shown.
- Yeah.
- And then of course I think Gears 5.
This was our big section,
we set the stage on fire,
we built a hive underground.
- It was so cool.
- We hit three
rustlers underneath.
- Lego Forza, okay other than
Keanu Reeves appearing on
stage, that was amazing.
But all the Lego games, 'coz I love Lego.
Obvioulsy Halo Infinite,
oh and then the new next gen Xbox.
- Project Scarlett.
- Coming holiday 2020
with Halo Infinite.
But Lego's out this week on the 13th.
- I'm so excited.
We'll be playing it, so stay tuned guys.
Okay bye!
Have a good E3.
- Survive E3!
- Oh my god this is so many Starbucks.
This makes me so happy.
I mean at a video game convention,
leaving the Xbox conference
with six coffees.
- You're like ready for this.
- So I always place an order at the end
of the Xbox press conference
and then I go and everything's ready.
When Keanu came out on stage,
I almost fell off of my freaking chair.
It was such a surprise.
I can't believe that didn't leak, at all.
- That was so cool.
- So good.
- So Cyberpunk was one of
the main things last year,
but the fact that we got that trailer,
which is phenomenal, and then like
oh, Keanu Reeves just walks out.
- It was so great, it was amazing.
I'm still shook.
- I'll let you go--
- Do you want a coffee,
'coz I bought too many.
- I'm going well into
my video, I'm all good.
Thank you.
- Okay bye.
I'm sorry I crashed your video, bye.
Austin everyone, can you believe it?
So we just left the press
conference here at Xbox,
what was your favorite thing?
Or least favorite thing,
whatever you wanna go.
- Well favorite things I
obviously Keanu coming out.
Like you just can't, there
was no comparison to that.
And then obviously Halo.
- Yeah, it was so great.
- With that you just can't.
Whenever you're like,
"Oh I'm not gonna play
"video games as much", and
you see something like that.
You see Halo and it
just pulls you back in.
- Okay, okay.
Let's go in.
- We'll see you inside.
- So we're inside the
Xbox showcase right now
and this is where we actually
get hands on with things
and I'm not sure what's gonna be in there,
but I'm hoping the Lego
Forza's gonna be there
because oh my gosh.
That game is gonna be so fun.
But it's actually gonna
be out in a few days,
so either way I'm gonna play it.
But let's go inside.
I've got my little
capture hard drive here,
so we can capture some gameplay.
They also have the new
Xbox Elite controller.
This is the second version
and I freaking love
this controller so much.
Let's go take a look at it.
(upbeat music)
Just got a chance to see the
new Xbox Elite controller
and now we're gonna head
in to play some games.
They told me that Lego Forza is in here.
Everyone's like, "Halo, Halo!"
Yes, I'm excited about Halo
but Lego Forza, come on!
Oh my god, it's beautiful.
It is absolutely beautiful.
(upbeat music)
I think I'm gonna get in it.
I'm gonna get in it, I'm getting in line.
I'm getting in line.
- [E3 Staff Member] If you
wanna sit in it you can too.
- Really?
You just gotta play it and then--
- Is this the line to play?
- This is the line.
- No way.
I'm so hyped.
All right.
- [In Game Character] Here's what I see
- We're starting out.
- [In Game Character] I
see a world made of bricks.
No, no listen.
And there'd be dinosaurs and pirate ships,
ghosts I guess?
Yeah, ghosts.
We'll build a city and cars
just as fast as the real thing.
We'll call it Lego Valley.
You in?
- Lego Valley.
I am so in.
This is so freaking fun.
The cows!
Oh god no!
Love this.
Oh no!
I'm hitting everything!
A soccer field?
This is gonna be great.
That was so much fun.
This is honestly a dream
that I didn't even know
that I wanted to come true.
- And there's a press start button up here
that'll turn on the engine for you.
- Really?
- Just step on the gas,
you'll hear it.
- Okay.
- Red button.
(engine revs)
- Oh look!
It's Sam Sheffer, PC boy.
- Have you ever played a
Halo with masked people?
- I actually have not.
- It is not that easy.
- Maybe--
- You wanna hop on?
- Maybe you're just
not that good.
No it's okay.
I don't want, okay, all right.
Okay, all right.
Am I playing against real people?
- It's a 10 minute demo.
So this will expire and
then you can start over.
- Did I die already?
- I don't think you're
supposed to go in there,
'coz things explode.
- Okay.
- Also, shifts are on.
We're out of dino rifle bullets.
- Okay, well.
So I'm having a good time.
(upbeat music)
We are just leaving the showcase.
I got a chance to play the Lego Forza game
and get in the McLaren Lego car.
- [Jenna] I was a little worried
about you getting in that.
- So what was your favorite thing you saw
at the press conference?
- Besides Keanu Reeves
coming out on stage,
and announcing Cyberpunk,
everyone was losing their mind.
I have to say that Gears looks
really, really incredible.
Project Scarlett, Halo.
- I'm excited about
that and I look forward
to more fun stuff from E3.
So with that, I'll see you guys later.
Go check out Jenna's channel and
that's it.
- Have a good day.
- You have a good day.
(upbeat music)